thank you very much thanks a lot for
like me right so i will talk about
tensity composition and how to do that
with the sum of squares relations this
joint work with based on two joint works
with the authors of the Union are so
Hopkins thank you ma Jonathan Chi and
seen who is in the audience so so let's
start with the saying what's the tensor
so tensor is a very simple object just
an array of numbers where you have
multiple indices okay and this
generalizes in a natural way vectors we
have 11 index and matrices where you
have two indices so more formally if you
have a three tensor over RT then you
know it's a linear combination of this
kind of guys and these are you know just
ripples of basis elements of rd and so
that's how or the space of tensors how
the hub space of three tensors over rd
looks like and there are special tensors
which will play a crucial role in the
stock and those are hot product
cleansers or rank want answers which
which come from a triple a single triple
of vectors in the underlying space a B
and C here and the coefficients of the
tender that they specify they depend you
know linearly dependent in this model in
your way on the inter coefficients of a
BNC in the Senate basis
just here and me maybe one remark so
sometimes in the literature about ten to
decomposition there's an effort to
distinguish between tensor products and
chronicle products and other kind of
products but reason is a bit mysterious
to me Celine in this talk this year will
be a new user product product for four
matrices we believe we will be treated
like the usual chronica product for four
vectors and matrices okay now why should
you care about tensors it turns out that
tens us are like a natural shape of data
they arise in many different contexts in
particular you look at if a multivariate
distribution and you look at its moments
then this corresponds to it's a natural
way a tensor over the space where the
distribution is you know of the
distribution and similarly if you have a
point if you have a multivariate
polynomial then the coefficients of that
material pannonian for a tensor finally
if you have a quantum system that is
composed of different parts then the in
each state of this quantum system lives
in a in space in the tens of space over
the states for the individual parts okay
so in that sense candles are pervasive
data structures and one so the final
evidence for that claim is the fact that
if you look at this new deep learning
software library turns out that they're
very basic I take a structure is tensors
some sense these is of a library such as
libraries to manipulate tensors it
simple ways okay and so this
it gives rise to the thesis that you
know tensors are the new matrices you
know in the same sense that you know
matrices we're able to tie together you
know wide range of diverse disciplines
you know tensor have the same ability
okay but it turns out that tensors have
some unique advantages over all matrices
so the just because they are richer in
particular you know there's a reason why
why these software libraries are not
based on matrices but they're based on
tensors somehow I cancers are deeper
that also means that you know if
necessary matrices then you know we
should you know it's the time for to
develop algorithms for the tender age so
you have to you know identify the
algorithmic challenges that come with
trying to deal with tenders and in here
always to to repeat some of this
dramatic success that we had for you
know developing for algorithms for
matrices in the last couple of centuries
you know you've seen amazing algorithms
for matrices which are trained or
dramatic impact in many ways and though
is to repeat some of that for tenses and
again there will be some unique
challenges in doing that and we will
discuss some of those okay so the
problem I want to focus on is 1030
composition which is arguably one of the
most fundamental problem support answers
so suppose you have a 310 sir what you
want to do is you want to explain this
310 sir in the simplest way possible
okay so with this as few vectors of the
underlying space as possible and the
kind of explanation that we if we look
for is these kind of module in your
explanations particular you want to find
you know as few vectors AI bi c is
possible such that the tens of T is some
of the the rank 1 tensor is
corresponding to AI bi and CI okay now
why would you want to do this so it
turns out that says I alluded to before
there are some key advantages that tends
to set over matrices and you know the
the key advantage that they have in this
context is that if you look at
factorizations for matrices then they
start off on the rotation problem what
this means is that if you have you know
some low rank factorization of of the
matrix then you can read right there are
different looking factorizations just by
you know transforming the vectors with
some arbitrary invertible in your
operation okay and it means that there
is no sense in which you know and in a
sense there they know that the major
sectors Asians are you know very non
unique and in contrast it turns out that
tens of the compositions are often
unique okay and this is very important
for you know in applications for tens of
decomposition because so if your idea is
to use this decomposition order to
explain the data in simplest way you
some hope that this explanation has
something to do with with some truth
that you're trying to find and now if
this if the solution is very under
undetermined like four matrix
factorization then you know it's it
becomes clear what it means that that
you find a good explanation but if you
if you find you know a low reg a tensor
decomposition and it has this property
that's unique then you know the vectors
that you find they they you probably
tell you something inherent about the
data that yeah
it's a little confused about the analogy
you say I'm equals a be transferred on
so I mean it isn't the right thing to
compare nowhere tensor products or outer
products yes that's the same thing so if
you look at rectangular matrix yes yes
yeah here you have rectangular matrices
maybe I so I guess I never gives me if
it's the columns or rows off of a RB by
N by K that's right k you're saying yes
yes also here the inner dimension would
be our and and that will bet that's the
same thing that you're trying to
minimize here the the the rows of a and
the rows of B will be the vector set
you're sorry the columns of a and the
columns of B would be the may correspond
to AI and bi am disk right yeah but i'm
still confused about why why you see
these cases is so different though
because I mean certainly the singular
value decomposition of the singular
values or distinct gives a pretty unique
way to write but then but this done but
then you if usually talk about new
single values then you have in mind that
the vectors that you're trying to find
should be orthogonal okay and then
you're right if you if you sort of know
a priori that my vectors are orthogonal
then that fixes or did that makes the
decomposition sometimes unique okay for
HSCs and actually then you just assume
that the singular values are all
different and m4 in the tensor case it
turns out that you know it can capture
you don't have to assume anything about
orthogonality of the often of the true
explanation here looking for okay thanks
and all formality of course in some
context this is perfectly justified but
in many contexts it's not
but I don't so this advantage comes with
the challenge and the chances that your
template 10 civilizations are and be
hard to compute in the worst case and
that means that that we can't hope to
have the same kind of you know very
simple theory that we had for computing
matrix accusations or other matrix
problems okay but but but but certainly
you know it doesn't mean that we can
talk to for good algorithms because you
know there are many cases like you know
for example the story about
approximation algorithms where we know
we have np-hard problems but we managed
to find you know interesting ways of
dealing with them finding proved
logarithms for them and so the hope is
to do you know that we can do the same
thing for ten to decomposition and it
turns out that you know this hope is
English it seems to be justified in SS
have some evidence that indeed you know
you can have very good algorithms for
these kind of problems and another nice
thing is that the jack ability of of the
of this problem seems to go hand in hand
with the uniqueness of the decomposition
is there some relationship a parent
relationship between these properties
you know when when you see tractable
defined ten sitting position and when is
a unique and so in the soccer we will
see why why is how these things are
indeed related okay and I don't just to
give you more example so it turns out
that indeed so efficient algorithms for
ten sitting position they gave rise to
know provably efficient and also
practically efficient algorithms for
wide range of learning problems all the
problems i listed here and in general
you know this answer lies dying problems
they try to ask you to cluster to
cluster some of the observations in a
particular way and turns out the best
boob logarithms are these problems are
based on density composition it also
means that if you reserve have better
algorithms for tens decomposition it
means that you can learn this problem or
you can so so these learning problems
okay so now to get some tea some I want
to show you what what is not about you
know the algorithmic difficulty of that
kind of I wouldn't be here for tens
decomposition that solid I want to it's
convenient to think about technique
musician it's like different way in a
sort of a probabilistic way and this way
you know some level the notation is a
little bit more familiar and which has
always also algorithms the they follow
this this viewpoint okay so so now we
consider this this problem so it's an
inverse problem and what were you trying
to do is you just have given some
moments of a distribution and you're
trying to find what's the original
distribution and so what's the precise
setting supposedly if you have some set
of vectors a 1 or 2 a and are unknown
and we are given the low degree moments
of a uniform distribution over these
vectors okay the first k moments of this
distribution and our goal is to recover
the original vectors okay so this is a
special case of the multivariate moment
problem and in such a reformation of the
tensor decomposition problem and our
question is you know under what
conditions on the vectors a 1 up to n
and number of moments k that we observe
i can we solve this problem efficiently
and robust key so basely means that even
if there are some air or on the moments
that you observe we should you won't be
able to solve this problem and there's a
you know classical case which you know
has its origin in the 1970s in a paper
by Harshman algorithm attributes to two
young reef and this this case quorum is
when when the vectors a 1 a 2 a n are
linearly independent notice it also
means that n is at most D in this case
it turns out that if they are linearly
independent you can without loss of
generality assume as they actually
orthonormal so often not orthogonal unit
vectors the reason is that you know if
you get the first three moments let's
say of this of these distribution
the second moment matrix allows you you
know to construct this linear
transformation in this life
transformation all phenomena is as the
vectors in so you can just push this
linear operation into everything that
you observe and then you know effect if
that allows you to assume that the
vectors are orthonormal and in this case
you can solve the problem in West good
as you could hope for so it turns out
that three moments I I need the first
three moments I need enough it's a very
simple I growth from spectral algorithm
based on Nino diagonalizing matrices and
you know it's a really nice tigress
might explain it later in the talk
because we will use it as a protein now
one interesting question here is what
happens if there's no is in the in the
input suppose that our input is not
something you know the sum of the rank
one with tenses of the a is but you know
there's some error tensor e added to it
and so now you can ask where is it
information theoretically possible to
solve to still solve this problem turns
out that if you know the injective norm
which is an analog of the spectral norm
for tensors this is much less than 1
then you can still solve the problem you
can see approximately recover the
vectors a1 after the N and there is a
polynomial time algorithm based on some
non convex creating this end i use
contents of power iteration which solves
the problem whenever the injective norm
is at most 1 over N okay so there's this
cape of 1 over n between the thing at
this information in theory get possible
and what what we know what point in to
do it point number time and in this
sword oh it is covered it's different
here we will give a pyrometer my growth
based on the sum of squares idea which I
will define later which says that which
shows that you can solve the problem
whenever some other norm the sum of
squares norm of the f of the error is
the most evil trick is with much less
than 1 so what is this norm this norm is
an efficient relaxation of the injective
norm it turns out that it satisfies that
you know for every error tensor the sum
of squares mom is in most squared n
times the injective norm and that means
that
you know this result actually dominates
so this condition is satisfied you know
more often than in this guy basically
there's a difference between these two
conditions there's a gap bit of lease
routine and turns out that if the if if
you know that the error is random and
take up the chosen from a new
independent Gaussian distribution then
the sum of squares norm is the most into
this one quarter larger than the
injective moment okay that means that
there's only get to enter one put into
the one quarter towards information
theoretically possible in this and
there's some some evidence that that
indeed like you can't it is difficult to
improve over this enter the one one
quarter in particular even if the number
of components is just one then we don't
know better algorithms for that and the
number of components is one so n is
equal to one and yet random arrow this
corresponds to a sarcastic model for
tens of PCA which was proposed by
montanari and Richard and so so so this
this bound here actually it's a veces
investigate let me know even if n is
equal to 1 for random tensors oh this is
to the positive side to your result is
under oath assumption on end ah are
positive side so they are of normals
which means that any said most D but the
other day again it can be equal to keep
that's right this exactly acid that's a
good person if you have a noise if it's
some error in input then you can you
know the amount the accuracy which you
want to recover the vectors you know it
depends on how large or how much the
noises and this and these thresholds
that I stated here they are the case
when you know when you can recover the
vectors up 2.9 in a point nine of their
mass so these are unit vectors so if you
see anyone this is the case and you can
get you know an epsilon approximation
for it
for the Wreckers yeah that's it ok so
this and I'll for the rest of the talk I
will ignore this issue about noise most
of the time whenever it's it's ok well I
mean it just is a remarkable so there's
a sense in which this algorithm place in
sum of squares they are almost
automatically robust to to noise which
is a nice feature that other algorithms
many other algorithms don't share now a
motel no case is instead of linearly
independent vectors so consider random
vectors where n is much larger than D ok
so I'm strange why do I say that this is
a more general case this is my channel
case if you because if you have um you
know linearly independent early
independent vectors by what we said we
can assume that the orthonormal and if
they often normal you can apply a random
rotation to them okay and now you know
if you apply the random rotation to
autonomic vectors you basically have in
a random unit vectors so it means that
you know there's a way of reducing the
linear independent case to random
vectors with and less than D now we ask
what what happens if you have random
vectors running unit vectors with n much
larger than D and suppose you only want
to use the first three moments of the of
the vectors so this this problem has
been cited only very recently and
thought to be quite quite quite a bit
harder than the case of linearly
independent vectors and the first result
in this context I said you know if you
have at most C times D for some constant
C bigger than 1 vectors then there's an
algorithm that can solve the problem
with the running time is exponential in
C
so this is reasonably if sees you know
logarithmic in indy and another
algorithm this is just using a spectral
algorithm and in this non convex crane
descent type algorithm it turns out that
even if the rank is t to the e to the
1.5 if you have d to the 1.5 factors you
can show that this vector this algorithm
has some local convergence guarantee in
the sense that you know if you start
very close to the solution then
algorithm finds the solution but this
doesn't correspond to like an efficient
algorithm because you know it doesn't
it's not clear how to get close enough
so this local convergence plays a role
and then the first algorithm that have
worked for significantly larger number
of vectors actually you know matching
the bound for for local convergence of
tens of power iteration it was placed in
sum of squares and you know it solves
the problem in quasi polynomial time so
which is a you know a bit larger than
point O Meal Time but but still
interesting interesting guaranteed and
this work okay so the question now is
can you you know solve this problem if
the if the rank is you know some point
on your factor larger than D employed on
your time and this talk we know we show
that this is indeed the case so there's
an algorithm based on sum of squares
which works up to the same bound for the
rank as before but runs now in point
normal time and you know actually
precursor of that result it's a result
which works up to some something that is
still point 0 merely larger than then D
and a rank of this program will after
the D and the test the nice feature that
it's much faster than you know it is
sort of an algorithm Belisarius
reasonably fast it runs in time you know
at most D to the 3.33 and notice that
this is pretty close to linear time
because the input has size t cubed
now you know going to more general kinds
of vectors we talk about linear
independent vectors random vectors now
you know another model that people said
it is smooth vectors so in this this
falls into the framework of spewing tang
of smooth analysis the other idea is
that we usually in smooth analysis the
idea is to picture the input and hope
that you can solve the problem on the
perturbed input now it turns out that
for this body for this kind of inverse
problems you want to be able do it a bit
differently so here the ideas that you
perturb the the sums is the solution if
you're trying to find you a job the
vectors and this induces of course the
perturbation of the of the of the of the
tensor which Jagran gets this input but
severe is very structure of kind of
perturbation and and then so the
algorithm you know gets this post
ruction structurally perturbed 1030 and
is trying to recover the the vectors and
here you know it's nice thing is that we
you know the amount of perturbation that
we apply to the vectors is extremely
small it's just a you know if they are
unit vectors then we perturb it by some
you know some polynomial amount yet you
know a Gaussian of it you know some
inverse point Omiya length and this can
be as small as you like and and here the
you know first result is that you know
in frozen 70 there's a point over time
algorithm that works if you have the
first four moments and it works up to
rank at most d squared okay a nice thing
is that so you know it on some level
only care this is large minimum effect a
larger than D and it's a somewhat
mysterious algorithm that you know
combines in a very ingenious way solving
large systems of linear equations and
this idea of these spectral techniques
from earlier algorithms but one
unfortunate aspect of this algorithm is
that it assumes that you have access to
the exact moments and it in particular
it's not known whether it tolerates that
point normal amount of noise and in many
applications are eager for this learning
vacations you really need to be able to
tolerate a point nominal amount of noise
if you want the algorithm trying to
point number time and that motivated
later paper by a vast all right I'll we
showed that if you sue if you have more
more moments you up to first five
moments then you know you can have the
same guarantee as this algorithm which
is for the foobie algorithm and but in
addition you can tolerate a point normal
amount of noise okay and in this talk we
will the techniques inference of that
expand in this talk they allow you to so
have the f the course of combined the
benefits of both of these results you
you know it shows that you indeed for
moments I enough if you want you know up
to up to this rank and and you can still
tolerate a polynomial amount of noise
and again this uses summer squares and
the nice thing about this part is that
you know the key ingredient here is to
to interpret the early algorithm this
could be algorithm is falling into the
sum of squares you know as a special
case of the kind of sum of squares
algorithm that we have been proposed
before he said turns out that on some
level this this this this algorithm here
it falls into this summer squares
framework it finally you know let you
know what can we do if you don't make
any assumptions about the vectors
suppose that we have completely general
unit vectors and just for simplicity
assume that we put them into isotropic
position he so now you know I told you
before that this problem is np-hard so
some of you know you would expect but
you shouldn't be able to do anything for
if you don't make any assumptions about
the vectors but turns out that you know
if you're in this viewpoint for in terms
of these inverse problems then then it
you know it's in make sense to ask this
question because so what we do is we
know we fix the vectors now we ask how
lapsed we have to choose the number of
moments in order for us to be able to
recover the vectors okay it turns out
that you know if you've been to spend or
the coin over time and you want to
recover the vectors up to it some
accuracy epsilon then if you get moments
up to degree it one of exelon times
logarithmic in
this ratio n divided by D then you know
you can recover the vectors and this
algorithm is based on sum of squares and
this techniques in this soccer allow you
to do the same achieve the same
guarantees but with the point no matter
my breath and this has also some
applications for dictionary learning
okay so let me see you what's the time
okay okay so now I try to give you some
of the ideas from the proof and so so
first let's let me explain this this
this very first it's very classical
algorithm that works for linearly
independent vectors and this migration
do to generate so you have access to the
first three moments and as I expend
before if you have linearly independent
vectors we can actually assume that they
also normal because the second moment
allows us to often normalize them okay
so now what can we do let me look at the
third moment so this is like a three
dimensional array of data and of numbers
and now what we'll do is we will choose
a standard Gaussian G in with the in
dimension D and we lie in this couch on
you know in this way with with our three
dimensional array of data and we will
use it to you know take a linear
combination of the slices you know then
surfaces it suggested in this diagram
and and this will result into a
two-dimensional right now and this is
matrix and and the algorithm it turns
out we'll just look at the eigenvectors
of that of that matrix ok now this
operation is called a contract because
you even tracked one index using this
using this vector g and now you know
before you get three indices and
afterwards you only have left two
indices and the linear algebra operation
it's just that you in multiply you apply
this linear transformation to the three
cancer the third moments where you know
you don't do anything to the first three
indices the first two indices and you
apply this linear functional G transpose
to the third index and the resulting
matrix you know
it's not very about exactly how this
works is it looks like this so that it's
a mating waiting of the outer product of
the vector say I and the coefficient is
the inner product of the vector G and a
high and now you know because we often
normalize the vectors these guys will be
eigen vectors of the of the matrix and
the eigenvalues are those coefficients
and because g was a random vector you
know and the vectors AI they are
orthogonal these are actually
independent gaussians and that means
that we know with probably one they're
all the setting of distinct and they
also reasonably far apart and that means
that if you compute the eigenvectors you
know that each I in space is
one-dimensional corresponding to one of
the eyes ok so that's that's great and
now the challenge is suppose that we you
know if we want to do this if if if if
the number of vectors is much larger and
then I mentioned and now the issue is
clearly that you know even if you know
if you do this operation then it can't
be the case that each AI is a you know
it's an eigenvector of the author matrix
because we just have you know d
eigenvectors / BF so let us work if you
have more than more than g vectors and
so so here's the approach the general
approach for dealing with the over
complete three tensors so we have a you
know DFS input is 3 tender and now we
imagine that we have in a some magic
procedure that allows us to enter
transform compute the the you know from
given the 310 sir given the three
moments that moments it allows us to
compute the the six moments of the
distribution okay now why would that be
good well if you look at the six moment
of the distribution you can think of it
as a third moment of the disk of the
uniform distribution over a one you know
tens of with itself up to a entenza with
itself okay and now these guys these
vectors you know if you choose a one or
two at random then these vectors they
essentially look like random unit
vectors in d square dimension you know
you know and this
you know this is good because we have in
a number of vectors that we have here is
much less than d squared and you know if
i choose you know much you know at most
you know d squared vector random vectors
in d square dimension then there will be
very close to orthogonal and that we end
in particular these guys they are close
enough to being orthogonal for january
again Rick's algorithm to burp okay so
that you know if it's just apply
generous algorithm you know do this
random contraction then it turns out
that the eigenvectors that you will get
they will be very close to to these guys
and from these guys I can recover the
vectors a 1 up to n so that's the the
plan it what's the weakness of the plan
the makers is that we assume this this
magical procedure that allowed us to
lift the third moments to sixth sixth
order moments and to get some intuition
about you know how we could go about
constructing this kind of metrical
procedure let's consider the following
ideal implementation which which we know
which will not be efficient but it will
sort of guide guide us to the right
thing to do and so what would be an
ideal implementation of this metric of
this magic box and one I'd you know I
delimiters nobody considers the
following suppose you want to leave this
magic book box it computes a
distribution deal over the unit's figure
which has the same third moments as the
given third moments and then just
outputs the six moments of the
distribution recompute okay
so you know what we would want to show
so with you is that if you do this if
you do the search over distributions
that I have the same you know third
moments as to given third moments we're
going to show is that this will result
into a distribution that has in whose
with 6mon is close to the true sixth
moments okay and notice that I mean what
one one key aspect of this box is that
be summer I have to insert of the
existence of this magic box it relies on
the fact that the third moments
determine the six moments right and
that's let's def by itself it's a
non-trivial effect which which is only
in which which will use the fact that
the vectors are random okay that's here
again sorry so so let's prove the fact
that let's prove this claim that the six
moments of the distribution that we
computed in this way that there will be
close to the six moments of the of our
vectors a 1 up to n so first of all
there are some equations that follow
from the fact that the you know the
third moments of of the resolution dr
the say it's the same as the third
moments of the vectors a 1 up to n so
first of all if you take the inner
product of the third moments of em of
the vectors with itself then you know
this will be a number of roughly 10
behind and you know but it but if this
guy is the same moment as the same third
moment as this then you know these two
you know these two inner products have
to be the same and this inner product it
turns out to be the expectation on the
distribution of of this this polynomial
normalize by 1 over n if the conclusion
of is this just some you know computing
consequences of this equation a
conclusion is that you know the
distribution d it satisfies the property
that you know under the solution d this
polynomial has expectation very close to
one ok and now if you look at this point
Omiya it turns out that you know the
high probability over the vectors i
would the choice of vectors a1 at the
end the way this point no me looks like
you know as a graph on the sphere it
looks like this so the only points where
where the point 0 mise large are at the
points a 1 up to a n
everywhere else it's very close to zero
and that means that you know that if the
distribution d satisfies this property
that the ex nail under the solution d
the expectation of this polynomial is
close to 1 it means that essentially the
distribution has to be supported on
vectors very close to a 1 up 2 a.m. okay
so in this sense and that means you know
if the distribution is indeed supported
on the you know essentially supported on
these vectors it also means that if you
look at the this polymer in a way every
race the inner products to the six this
will also be very close to one in
expectation on the distribution it's
just because you know if you plug in
each of these vectors in s su here you
will get something that is essentially
one and now you know we can do with this
this of the reverse calculation admitted
here you know here which we showed that
the fact that m3 is equal to the third
moments of d it implies that this is
large turns out that this is essentially
some equivalents and then you know if
you go backwards this mr. implies that
the six moment of the vectors are close
to the six moments of the distribution
will be computed okay that's what we
wanted okay great so now we show this
claim that the six moments of the
decision will be computed is close to
the six moment the truth six moments now
they're two remaining questions and one
question is you know this ideal
implementation is not efficient because
we you know this is pretending that we
could search over these distributions so
we have to somehow find a efficient way
of doing that a second question is you
know the kind of error that we have here
it has to be it should be the case that
young rich can tolerate this error he
because you know now we you know we feed
you know this kind of thing which is
only close to this we feel it again race
algorithm so you know Jana tiger isn't
better should we tolerate or no tolerant
enough to cope with the Darrow so it
turns out to be very a principled way of
dealing with the first question turns
out that instead of optimizing of all
disabuse ins we can optimize over a more
general set of objects called sir
distributions and this comes from the
sum of squares framework and now and his
laptop deals is an extent with the first
question the second question you can
tolerate the can can generate tolerate
this kind of error so here the answer
turns out to be no they are so large
okay so that's the problem so what do we
do well and okay then you can sort of
see it what's the problem right because
if you sort of remember the calculation
of it here we it's actually showed that
you know these these two guys are close
in Euclidean distance but but yeah Drake
energy algorithm relies on on you know I
mean values you know magnitudes of
eigenvalues and and that means that if
you know if I and end all these spectral
gaps and it means that if you know if
ifs of these this kind of the kind of
this kind of you know error that we have
here it can sort of contribute a small
number of very bad eigenvalues and that
will be a bit prey on your side rhythm
and in some sense this is a problem
because we don't really have any because
we be so think of you know implementing
this magic boxes of this kind of search
we don't really have much control over
in what kind of distribution we get from
from this box and until the idea is to
add an additional constraint to the
search which is similar to in spirit to
a maximum entropy constraint and so what
we want is that if you look at the
spectral norm of the fourth moment of
the resolution d this should be small
you know as small as you can hope in
something said this would be as small as
the spectral norm of the fourth moment
of the of the first moment of the
vectors a 1 up to n do you mean by this
external force yeah yeah that's that's a
good question so here we shape it as a d
square by d square matrix yeah but of
course I was hoping no one is very
different distributions
is yes I mean if I just tell you that
the distribution satisfies this property
our cases if it matches exactly the
third moments yes yes so so even if I
just tell you this property it's you
know you can take any two flexible you
can take the true distribution the over
uniform over a 1 up to n and then add
some adversarial but small error to each
vector a I and it will still satisfy the
property and and and if you know if you
add the adversarial error to EJ I you
know if we solve it could you choose
it's such a it's the same you had an
arrow in the same direction forever
every AI and this will contribute a very
large item value inn in every resource
resulting computation which is exactly
the only one then okay I don't know it
that's a good question i don't know how
to exploit the fact that matches exactly
that's a good question i I would doubt
that that it makes a big big difference
okay because on some level you know like
we're not on some level even is this
ideal implementation it's not doing the
right thing right because in the really
right thing would be to to opt to look
only at distributions that you know the
distributed over n vectors that look
like random vectors okay so to search
over you know every every distribution
that it looks like the kind of
distribution that we be assuming and the
fact that we are sort of look they'll be
looking at an arbitrary distribution
over the sphere and just require that
the third moments match it leaves a lot
of freedom it makes match because it's
sort of so in substance this maximum
entropy constrained it it doesn't really
improve the errors viega but it turns
out that this this this allows us to to
control the effect of the air or four
generous algorithm at the end and I hope
that I can show this so okay so what are
so now we you know the only thing we
have to do is you have to deal with
these two kinds of questions so let's
give you the first question so instead
of you know optimizing of all these
abuses V optimized overseer
distributions and on some level you know
okay so let me just so serious reasons
are in organization of actual
distribution where low complexity events
you know behave like you would expect
they've non-negative probability and
everything is nice but all bets are off
if you have high complexity events and
the notion of low complexity in high
complexity events is a specific and it
if it course you know you see next so
finally you know this degree DC you know
distribution is just a function on the
sphere and such that if you as it's a
finitely supported that if you set up
the values of the function you get one
okay that's what you would expect from
globalization and but it's not a
non-negative fans not necessarily no
negative function but it has the
property that if you take the if you
look at you know the the inner product
of the function d with any any square of
a low decree point o meu this will be
non-negative okay so these are the
simple events that have non-negative
probabilities and it turns out that you
know if you change the
the degree requirement here for the
functions then you know you get smaller
and smaller sets and if you choose you
know fill out here if you love functions
of arbitrary degree that would imply
that the function capital d is is no
negative everywhere so it means that
really corresponds to uniform
distribution but everything intermediate
is a more general object and now we you
know it can formally define an
expectation under this serious abuse and
II just like we would be for for actual
distributions and you know now the
advantage of of two distributions is
that you know unlike for extra
distributions we can we can optimize
over these distributions efficient of
these no general distribution
sufficiently particular there's a
separation Oracle which runs in time e
to the K for this for the set of for the
convex set of students additions and
this means that you know if you have
some if you know basically every
optimization problem if you would like
to solve about dissolutions you can
solve it efficiently for student
solutions ok so maybe less I can feel as
a take-home message you know if you ever
encounter in a field you feel yourself
you know that if you ever end the
position of you know wanting to optimize
our distributions but you know you you
know it's up to you how to do it then
you know just so you can you can try to
optimize over to distributions and you
know some luck it will work yes just as
well can't it turns out that and this
idea of serious business also it's a way
of capturing the best known point only
time algorithms for large class of our
problems so on some level like this is
the best way of best efficient way of
relaxing distributions that we know of
re is why it's definitely supported
assumption you can always make the final
results okay so here I did it just
because I didn't want to write integral
of course if I'd make this assumption
it's not really convex right because you
know only sort of like limiting object
will be convex but yeah it will not you
know if you just watch the boy dealing
with measures he really issues but but
we are finally supported you because on
some level you can assume that these
these these functions are really this
capital
this function capital d you can assume
that it's a degree it has decreed most
pain so it's a low degree point o meal
and and then you know and that sort of
means that that you can specify you know
as a finely supported distribution
finally support function
so maybe that means skip this okay so
this is there's a notion of sum of
squares plus which is an abstraction of
the kind of properties that hold for two
distributions that are true in the real
world and also good for for serious
abuse ins let's let's out not go into
that and so it's a one thing that not
what we want to do is you know we before
we said that we said we saw proved that
if you have an actual distribution whose
degree 3 moment is the same as as a free
moment of our vectors then the degree 6
moment is this is close to the e36
moment of our vectors and if you recall
that proof actually the only thing that
we used is the fact that if if this
point O Meal I slaps expectation under D
and the distribution d then also this
point no meal has large expectation
under under under under d & n that means
that on that on some level we just have
to prove that this inequality is still
true for su distributions and you know
this this this can be done and it boils
down to proving pounds on the spectral
norm of of this kind of matrix
polynomials which are you know
unfortunately don't have a general and
good channel to its for for doing that
but it turns out that for this
particular matrix bueno Mia we can prove
good bound with good bones on its
spectral norm so this this address is
the first issue you know trying to
replace you know the search over the
solutions with the search over Sulia
solutions and so this means that you
know nothing changed now the second
issue it's a substance in orthogonal
issue and here we want to say that this
additional constraint that into the
spectral norm of the computed
distribution of attic of the author of
the moments of the computers abuse is
small and this allows us to say that
Jenrry here still works and the variable
sales is that will show that if you do
this random contraction then the top
icon vector of the resulting matrix will
be close to one of the vectors a sub I
and okay so maybe the adjuster and show
you in a high level work what's
happening so if you do this random
contraction you can think about it is
doing a random contraction in the in the
in the direction ai and a random
direction orthogonal to the direction AI
yeah and now so that means that this
random contraction you know it naturally
the Pico bosses in something I know it
parallel to a I entered a orthogonal
trip to a I and turns out that the
condition that our moments are closed in
Euclidean norm to the true moments this
allows to show that this behaves nicely
and the fact that the that we have is
entropy constraint it allows us to show
that this orthogonal part behaves nicely
okay and now you know what you wanna
yeah let me skip the calculation here um
think I'll also skip all of that so this
was ok so maybe let me just work here so
you know one unfortunate aspect of of
this eigersund le described is that it
uses this it optimizes your suitor
distributions which is a very slow
process in general and you would like to
have this ought to do this fast and it
turns out that um you know on some level
what you wanted to do here is not you
didn't want to you know the only thing I
do you want to do is you find an object
here that fools Henry sy dress and that
behaves like a true six moments too
generous algorithm and it turns out that
you know if you can you could you can
hope you can do to some extent implement
this kind of procedure in a very simple
way just as a polynomial of the of the
input tensor as a low degree polynomial
of the input tensor and this this object
here turns out to be a polynomial degree
three point on will indian Putin's
tensor and and this turns out to you
know fool generous algorithm in the same
sense that the the moments of the
distribution that we computed before
food vendors
rhythm and this gives an a fast
algorithm in particular Road runs in
time e to the 3 point 33 so skip that we
conclude so so we saw us a way of using
sum of squares for tensity composition
and the day there were two parts here
one was to use to give us a most players
to give a proof that is valid for serial
distributions which shows that the the
third moments determine up to some small
error the six moments and the second
part was to to show that you know the
the January's algorithm can be used as a
rounding algorithm for the for that for
the kind of you know sir distributions
that are computed by by sum of squares
and then you know there's a way of
obtaining fast algorithms from this sum
of squares viewpoint by instead of
computing serious abuse ins it's enough
to know compute some no decree matrix
polynomial of the input which will be
the with the aim of fooling the rounding
I'd rhythm that I know that we had here
to open questions so one is um so
somebody saw us a way of decomposing
random three tens us better by the rank
is at most D 2 1.5 so this theta 1.5 is
a bit mysterious but it seems to be like
the right answer in the sense that in
the following sense so it is possible
information theoretically to decompose
random three tensors even if you do even
if you have n squared back d squared
vectors okay but but but but but but but
it seems to be that going beyond key to
1.5 you you you run into some inherent
computational complexity issues and it
would be nice to formalize this this
feeling and final thing is said so when
we talked about the smooth analysis for
veracity compilation we saw that there's
a way of doing 5 10 zones and for
tensors
and it would be great to be able to also
sort of have a smooth analysis for over
complete three tenders okay and and you
know done something that would be let me
be a very great strengthening of our
result for over complete for for random
over complete cancers okay thank you
very much
thanks